much for staying with us here at 4 30
I'm Christian Casitas and I'm
all right remember the grasshopper
Invasion that was back in 2019 well if
you didn't live here back then well it
was a grasshopper Invasion here in Las
Vegas at the end of July taking over the
strip and now it's a big concern again
yeah many of you have reached out to us
saying you're seeing a lot of these guys
could we have another infestation Mary
Jane billyeza found the answer as well
as some other insects that might be
bugging you this time of year
with the recent sightings of
grasshoppers and crickets around the
valley eight news now viewers are
wondering what to expect the next few
months they were just chirping and
chirping and chirping at a very very
strong level Trish Nash spent hours
trying to figure out where the noise was
coming from in her Henderson home before
discovering a group of crickets and
grasshoppers made their way into her
vent garage and laundry room I contacted
a pest control company and asked them
you know what their thoughts were about
this and they just explained that it's
really nothing that they can
you can't really
um control them as uh with the service
because they're just going to continue
to come sightings aren't just limited to
Henderson eight news now viewers reports
seeing these insects in Summerlin
Mountains Edge Centennial Hills North
Las Vegas the Thomas and Mack parking
lot at UNLV and even right here in the
channel 8 parking lot could Las Vegas
see another grasshopper infestation I
have seen so many out here field
biologist Maria minich says it's
possible I think 2019 was a different
year because it was it was a lot drier
than it we had more Monsoon this year
more rains so I don't honestly believe
that it's going to be that bad but it
could get worse minich says readily
available food sources grasshoppers feed
on like other smaller insects and plants
are keeping them thriving along with the
change in climate conditions she says
don't be surprised if you continue to
see grasshoppers stick around we had a
pretty hot dry summer we did have some
Monsoon definitely but those combined
those factors combine
are just allowing this explosion of the
population these insects are harmless if
you come across them it's best to leave
them alone Mary Jane beliesza 8 News Now
while grasshoppers move around they fly
to find food so you might see them
traveling alone or in large groups